the appeal of the self-effacing comedy
is I don't think that it is the debate
the debating of oneself I think it is
the appeal of humility which I think
we're all kind of grappling for but I
think it's it's all in doses I think the
similar to pop songs and music being
more popular of a certain flavor at a
certain time you know supposedly there's
a study that during horrible economic
periods songs that are most hopeful are
more popular and then during economic
booms the more dark Nirvana type music
is more popular I don't know if that's
true that's what I read a million years
ago so I think identification in this
human experience is a very appealing
thing and I think that surprise moment
which is very similar to laughter it's
it's you know this moment of
acknowledgement and a moment of being
out of control and maybe a glimpse into
ourselves is really important and an
insight into ourselves I realize that
there is a certain victimization complex
that I have that I probably had all my
life you know and again compared to you
know african-americans or women or
people in the LGBTQ community it's
nothing but like being the whitest white
guy was a burden and in a way maybe
we're all we all have a victimization
complex in
and and we kind of illustrate that and
hopefully a very humorous way through
these episodes and it's interesting to
read to write and create something and
then edit it and see it in its entirety
that what is your sensibility what is
your point of view because I knew that I
have always known that my comedy was
self effacing and an observational but I
didn't realize some of the psychology
behind it and even when you write jokes
when I write jokes I'll get to you know
there's different lines that that you
know humor and sarcasm is like liberty
it's ever expanding and moving but the
line of self effacing just as the line
of irreverence is always moving so
someone just getting on stage and saying
I'm ugly is not funny but it could be
funny you know you know self-awareness
is a pretty compelling attribute among
other human beings and I think that that
self-awareness is something that it's
very similar to observational humor it's
an insight to humanity so me going on
stage and saying I know I'm a pale guy
who is out of shape I think makes puts
people at ease because there are so many
of us and including myself that do not
have this self-awareness that thinks
because we all think that we're in a
movie about our lives right